time and time again netflix has proven
itself to be the perfect place for
audiences to discover
overlooked movies and for those
overlooked movies to finally get some
eyes on them
perhaps it's due to the wider audience
or the ease of browsing for new flicks
to watch
but either way a lot of box office flops
and critical bombs have netflix to thank
for their viewership
one of those flops is a 2020 sci-fi
action movie
skylines currently dominating netflix's
viewership chats
the dystopian adventure is actually the
third entry in the skyline franchise
following 2010 skyline and 2017's beyond
skyline
sadly the trilogy got started on a less
than ideal note with the 2010 original
tanking at the box office
and receiving mostly poor reviews from
critics however beyond skyline rejected
the sophomore slump expectation
and wound up earning pretty solid
reviews even if audiences still weren't
totally on board with the franchise
things are looking up kid skylines
debuted in theaters and on apple tv in
december 2020 but its arrival on netflix
in march 2021 has breathed new life into
the film
as of march 23rd skylines has remained
in the list of netflix's top 10 most
watched movies in the us
for several days something not many
other projects film or otherwise have
achieved
directed by liam o'donnell who also
wrote the film script
skylines picks up where the second film
left off now grown-up resistance leader
captain rose cawley is leading a team of
elite mercenaries
including both humans and biomechanical
entities that were formally enslaved as
soldiers
the end of beyond skyline saw rose and
her team flying around the moon
attacking other ships at the start of
skylines a human portion of the crew is
focused on battling the harvester
mothership known as the armada
which will use its weapons to blow up
earth rose sits a crossroads when she
realizes that the only way she can
defeat the armada and save earth
is to put one of her own ships in the
line of fire a move that could only
result in everyone on the ship dying
she makes a difficult decision in order
to protect earth then disappears for
half a decade as she works through her
guilt and grief
when rose emerges living in london
amongst pilot aliens and trying to keep
herself hidden from leon
humanity has changed a virus breaks out
and turns into a pandemic
affecting pilots and anyone who has
pilot parts it destroys not only the
pilots bodies but also their minds
causing them to revert back to their
original hostile selves
pilots are dying what you saw today
is only the beginning it's up to rose
and her team to put an end to the virus
before it's too late
the group heads to the alien's home
planet in an attempt to save the world
at the time of its release skylines
didn't blow people away not critics and
not general audiences
some reviews were mostly negative and
some were rather glowing
but across the board critics felt that
skylines was kind of like its title
a middle-of-the-road movie that rests on
the horizon line polygon's tasha
robinson put it best when she wrote in
her review of the film
skylines feels like the respectable
30-something iteration of a familiar
friend
who used to be a rowdy teen and a
reckless and wild 20-something
it's perfectly passable low-key science
fiction almost certainly destined for a
fast trip to netflix where it can be
taken up as an amiable evening's viewing
netflix is exactly where skylines ended
up and subscribers are now singing the
film's praises
one twitter user wrote skylines is
honestly a good movie and i hope y'all
will watch it now that it's on netflix
because it's so worth it and that it's
what the cast and crew deserve
critique matthew essery even took the
time to share a six-tweet thread about
skyline's merits
writing in part i wanted to let you know
that the incredibly fun sci-fi sequel
skylines is on netflix starting today
march 18 2021 it joins the previous
entry in the series beyond skyline on
the services
and these two films form an excellent
standalone sci-fi tale i legitimately
love skylines and the earlier beyond
skyline and i think you will too
if you're in the mood for a fun
action-packed adventure skylines is
worth adding to your must-watch list
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one